music to the ears of motorsports fans
after a 16-year hiatus from the top
class of the le mans endurance series
porsche will be making its long overdue
return to lmp1 next summer the car
maker's slogan is straight forward
enough mission 2014 our return
despite the lengthy layoff porsche is
still the record title holder at le mans
and is not just here for nostalgia or to
make up the numbers
porsche essentially started from scratch
explains its director of lmp1
engineering they had a tiny team toiling
away on the concept but which then grew
rapidly there's been a lot of work
involved they basically had a moving
target principle as regards the
regulations
the new regulations present tough
challenges to both the engineers and the
drivers
timo bernhard will be on the grid
proportion next summer in the le mans
prototype 1 class or lmp1
porsche's return in 2014 will be
accompanied by new regulations which
incorporate a far greater emphasis on
efficiency that means driving as quickly
as possible while using a minimum of
fuel
new challenges that will also raise the
pulses of old hands
former racing director manfred yanke
explains the differences
the biggest difference between the old
days and now is vehicle operation
back then you had more time so you
tended to break and shift all the way
down
which would take several seconds
these days it's all more intense
and the gears engage just like that
the pressure for the driver today is
having to manage everything in fast
motion
porsches have never been slow coaches of
course but this is le mans plus there's
greater pressure because of the car
maker's long absence
hans hammond co-steered porsche to its
first outright le mans victory in 1970.
this is the continuity the continuity
the ambition and the reliability are all
crucial as well as being super fast you
have to keep that up for a long distance
and you want that performance over many
years i hope that in 2014 porsche will
pick up where it left off
the gate
porsche's lmp1 boss fritz ensign and his
team are out to establish a new era and
the marriage of top performance and
efficiency is also of interest to
regular car buyers
the appeal of le mans lies in the mix of
team spirit strategy and engineering
a 24-hour race is obviously really long
there's excitement surrounding the whole
enterprise and the special appeal for
the manufacturer is demonstrating the
technology and durability
uh
le mans is a showcase for technology but
also a useful proving ground when it
comes to potential features for
production cars
former driver jurgen bart is delighted
to see lamar once more becoming a
standard bearer of future technology
you have all the hybrid developments
with the restricted fuel volumes the
electronic assists and what have you
his only concern is for the driver
having to keep his eye on too many other
things and perhaps forgetting to focus
on the track
of underserved
and this is the baby that will be on the
track next summer porsche is being
rather coy about details especially as
its rivals have a head start when it
comes to hybrid experience
we are definitely underdogs but that
doesn't mean we don't have a chance or
believe that we can't win
mission 2014 our return a return to
glory former race ace richard atwood
reckons his old team will surprise many
i
think
my money might be with porsche
two-time the man winner kris van lena is
likewise expecting porsche to triumph
i think it's great for the brand and the
company they definitely have a chance of
winning i'll bet on that
chance